lener with us after that crazy finish to
that time scramble in that game but
lener you had a difficult game today
with the black piece against uh a player
that you know oh so well Fabiano caruana
and you defend it very accurately how
are you feeling about your performance
in this
game yeah I mean um it's it was a tough
game um I played this idea with B5 in
the opening which is kind of unusual um
taking the game from typical Italian
positions I think more to Spanish
positions more like a marshall or or
Bishop C5 and um I thought Bishop B6 was
uh was precise but I'm not sure because
I'm
I'm stopping I mean not really stopping
but the the idea is always to meet
Bishop B5 with Knight A7 but then after
Knight C4 I I spend uh my my usual 40
minute uh think uh because I didn't
understand exactly uh how I should
proceed there are many lines but I
didn't see anything that um that I liked
uh um so much for example um and one of
the things that we were struggling with
was all these changes in Pawn structures
were you experiencing the same uh the
same
Traves yeah of course uh so many
different uh structures and a bit
unusual structures like for example I
could get this night 5 a and then Knight
takes B6 CB with the with the B Pawn
With The Pawn on B4 and the pawn on B2
or without the
pawns uh yeah so um I can allow white to
play C4 and then I can also take on C3
and go for this position which which is
what I finally decided but uh but yeah I
was I was trying to to see if uh if
there is U any other for example there
was Bishop takes F2 also interesting
move K Tak and then C6 but then yeah
instead of bc3
mhm Bishop takes F2 here King takes F
two C6 C6 yeah but then there is Knight
takes D6 I thought it seems like C takes
B4 gives white a decisive
Advantage CB
AB Knight takes no I mean A4 ah a takes
B4 then maybe Knight takes uh B6 no no
no I mean in instead of instead of
cb5 a takes B4 here yes Bishop to E3 but
then Knight takes D6 probably Bishop to
E3 Bishop B3 oh yeah CB AB yes and he
lose yeah I had I had also similar idea
to play uh also after BC BC Bishop C5
with the idea to play
C6 um BC uh BC Bishop B5 yeah yeah
Bishop no I thought Bishop C5
um in this position Knight takes A5 and
C6 mhm uh Knight takes
C6 Knight takes Bishop
takes Bishop takes Bishop takes F2 and
King takes F2 Queen B6 and I thought if
Bishop E3 Queen C6 there is some
compensation but yeah of course Knight
D4 here wins yeah Knight D4 if you take
I take your Rook so so yeah I think I
play played uh I played more or less
normal and it should be slightly worse
um but then uh yeah I was expecting more
AB uh to be honest instead of CB and he
played CB very quickly uh tell us about
differ I this
position between ab and basically I
didn't I didn't really consider CB much
I thought it's it's leads to a
symmetrical structure and black should
be more or less fine although it's also
worse but I was more concerned about AB
because then then his Pawn structure is
very solid and um uh in the long term I
could I could have some some issues with
these pawns on B6 and D6 and so at some
point you go Bishop A3 maybe Rook a C1
and then D4
yeah yeah so I thought I would play
Knight D7 on F5 but it still should be
should be better for white here I think
yeah yeah no you were right in your so
yeah after after CB after CB I was I was
uh a surprise and then I thought yeah
it's also worse but then when I found
this D5 I was happy because at least uh
I mean I'm I'm down upon but then my
play is it's uh much easier somehow Y
and you set up a beautiful blockade it
was quite funny we were looking at this
position with the engines and at some
point after this move Queen G3 it was
actually giving you the advantage after
this move Rook to E6 uh with a pawn down
did you ever think that in this position
you could potentially be better
yeah I mean uh black is so solid now
with the Knight on D5 and this Knight on
C6 it's it's a bit a bit funny there it
has no no much prospects so I I did see
like if I could take the E file somehow
someday I could be even better but um I
was so short on time that I decided to
play uh my moves uh quickly I I saw a
natural move and I just played it I
didn't bother to to look for Al
Alternatives at this point well lener
still a very good and positive result
for you with the black piece drawing
against the defending Champion
congratulations go get your energy guys
any questions for uh just great defense
lanir keep it up